Bladesmiths,
welcome to The Forge.
Eric, it's good to see you.
Good to see you.
GRADY: Jesse, you've tallied
up a total of $40,000.
And if you win out, you stand a
chance at taking home $50,000.
But, Eric, if you
came out on top,
that's your first
Gladiator of the Forge win.
And you'll get a $5,000 check.
And we'll ask if you wanna come
join us in the final battle
of this competition series.
You're gonna be building
this, the Acinaces.
DAVID BAKER (VOICEOVER): The
Acinaces traces its origin
back to the first millennium
BC all across the Mediterranean
region.
This deadly double-edged dagger
was used by Roman gladiators
in pairs, allowing them
to deliver quick slashes
and deadly strikes upon
opponents inside the walls
of the Colosseum.
This weapon was so
fierce it was even
believed to have been
wielded by Mithras,
the Persian god of the sun.
Now, along with the
weapon, we have also
chosen the forge
welding technique
that we want you both to
use to build your blades.
Now, if you look in
the pantry, you'll
see we have stacks of 1095 and
15n20 high carbon steel bars.
We want you to take
that steel and turn it
into at least 100-layer
twisted Damascus billet
from which you will
make your blades.
So work hard, stay sharp.
Your time starts now.
I always have the
tendency to pick too
much material at the beginning.
So I set four layers
off to the side.
That leaves me with
20 layers, which
means I have to cut and restack
5 pieces to get 100 layers.
So now that my
billet is drawn out--
Come on.
--I need to get this thing
cut into five pieces.
Jesse's not a big guy.
So I wonder how difficult it's
gonna be for him to actually
twist this hot steel.
OK.
Let's see how well this work.
J. NEILSON: Step on the plate.
Stand on those.
You're helping to anchor it
and you got better leverage.
[bleep] it.
Good enough for me.
I already have my blade
mostly forged to shape,
and I get ready for the quench.
If this quench
fails, it could send
me home and end my win streak.
Here we go.
Jesse is now in the oil.
That's great.
It went perfectly.
The blade looks great.
There's no cracks.
I heard no pings.
Things have been going
great in this round so far.
So now, I need to make an
anthropomorphic handle.
So I grabbed some mild steel.
It'll be a lot lighter in
the end, rather than brass.
OK.
My blade looks menacing.
It looks terrifyingly sharp.
The grind lines are
pretty much perfect.
And then, my handle
is just a person.
[laughs] Sounded great.
ERIC: I'm going
to use 22 pieces,
draw it out, split
it into five pieces,
restack it, and draw it again.
That'll put me at 110 layers.
I'm scared that once
I start twisting,
I'm just gonna see layers
start pulling apart.
If this fails, there's
no way I'm gonna come
back to win this challenge.
Oh, yeah.
Everything on my
steel looks good.
It's time to throw
it in the oil.
J. NEILSON: Oh, there you go.
All right.
GRADY POWELL: We got
two quenched blades.
Colors in that blade
look pretty good when
you put it in the oil.
Think I got a good
solid blade here.
Some days I even amaze myself.
My sword, it's
gotten a lot lighter.
And I wanna make sure
I leave that tang
a little on the heavy side
and bring that balance back
a little closer to the handle.
Now, it's time to get
this handle glued up.
It's a little man.
He, he, he.
The rest of the time
I have left is devoted
to sharpening this blade.
I couldn't be happier with the
way this blade's turning out.
GRADY POWELL: 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, put
down your tools.
This round is over.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test.
Today, we have the
Roman Throne Chop.
And since you
didn't get a chance
to pick the technique
or the weapon,
you get to choose
who goes first.
What?
- I'll take it.
- All right.
Eric, you wanna go first?
Let's do it, bud.
[grunting]
All right, Eric.
I gotta, say, good job, man.
All right.
First of all, there's no
deflection, deformation.
It came out nice.
Did a good job.
If we could etch this thing
for like another two hours,
this thing would
be amazing looking.
But the one complaint
I have is there
is a ton of weight on here.
Controlling that
during chops, it rolled
over on me a couple times.
Other than that, good job.
Thank you.
All right, Jesse.
You're up.
You ready to go?
No.
Well, we're
gonna do it anyway.
JESSE: I can tell that
the purpose of this chair
is to destroy blades.
It's been such a long road.
But this-- this could be
the beginning of the end.
I may not be here
for the next battle.
[grunting]
All right, Jesse.
Nice job.
It's nice and light.
It did a good job on the throne.
The edge is fine.
Everything's still
tight and true.
Good job.
Thank you.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Gladiators
of the Forge, this is it.
This is the sharpness test.
I'm gonna take your weapons and
try to cut through these ropes.
Eric, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's do it, Doug.
Let's do it.
Damn.
Better.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right, Eric.
Let's talk about
your sword here.
You have a sharp edge.
But there is a
weight to your weapon
that makes it hard
to hold on to.
It did cut most of the ropes.
But overall, it will cut.
Jesse, your turn.
You ready?
- Sure.
- All right.
Let's do it.
[bleep].
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right, Jesse.
Let's talk about
your weapon here.
First up, your edge
cut most of the rope,
except for the last one.
But I cut at different angles.
So I'll call that on me.
But it is sharp.
What I love about this
is the balance and weight
you have on your weapon.
Overall, it will cut.
Now, guys, both of your
blades performed extremely well
during our tests, which makes
for a very difficult decision
for our judges, because now,
they have to decide which one
of you is taking home
that $5,000 check
and the title of
Gladiator of the Forge.
Jesse, if you win,
that's seven total wins
and $45,000 in your pocket.
Eric, if you came
out on top, that's
your first Gladiator
of the Forge
win in a redemption round.
And you'll get a
$5,000 check, and we'll
ask if you want to come
join us in the final battle
of this competition series.
Our judges did make
a final decision.
Gentleman, the Gladiator
of the Forge today is--
Jesse, congratulations.
You did it again, man.
Eric, it's been an
honor to watch you work.
But unfortunately, your
blade did not make the cut
by the smallest of margins.
And J. is gonna tell you why.
J. NEILSON: It basically
just came down to weight.
There was so much
weight in that handle.
It made it harder to control.
And that's the reason
we're sending you home.
I get it.
At least I made you guys
work for it this time.
Jesse, that is seven
battles and seven victories.
You just won another
check for $5,000.
Well done.
You now have $45,000
in your pocket
and you are 7 titles in,
with a chance for one more
if you have enough in you to
go back in the Forge and battle
again.
What do you say?
Yeah.
Fantastic.
I can see the finish line.
Why not keep going?
What just happened?
I'm somehow the seven time
Gladiator of the Forge.
Awesome, man.
Well, congratulations again.
We can't wait to see you battle
it out in the final battle.
Well done, man.
Thank you.
I keep on saying
that this battle is
closer than my previous battle.
I can't imagine a
scenario in which it'll
be closer for the next battle.
I never expected to be
fighting for the last 5 grand
to 50 grand.
But I'm gonna keep my
place on the throne.